bonjour, je m'appelle Aaron Gilbert, docteur, une
particule, mettons-en une partout,
d'ailleurs, dans chaque fissure très difficile à
laver, nous avons consacré toute notre
vie à étudier le paranormal, maintenant
leurs observations partout dans la ville, il y a des
gens qui ont besoin de notre aide.
Boltzmann tu es un brillant ingénieur
Aaron personne n'est meilleur que toi en physique quantique
je le fais toujours je rejoins
le club je sais que New York tu es bonjour
je suis là pour le travail de réceptionniste salut
tu es embauché
allons-y  allons-y oh, est-ce que tu voulais tout, d'accord,
je te laisserai plus tard,
quelqu'un est en train de créer un appareil qui
amplifie l'activité paranormale ouais, nous
devons construire quelque chose pour combattre, ils
tiennent debout, les gars,
ok, je ne sais pas si c'était une question de race
ou une dame.  chose mais je suis en colère comme l'enfer
oui Kevin va créer quelques
logos pour nous mmm oh tu vois à quel point cela
pourrait nous faire mal paraître, est-ce que ce sont les seins que
tu n'aimes pas parce que je peux le rendre plus gros